All right, tech. So, you wanted to touch
on when the cor when the Torah gospel
was corrupted, whether before Muhammad's
time or after, and that whole thing.
What what was on your mind?
Yeah. Um, do you believe that there are
fabricated scriptures that are
attributed to the disciples?
Yeah.
So, that's fabricated, right?
Yep.
Do people exist who might believe that
these scriptures are true?
I don't know. Uh, once upon a time they
existed. I don't know if they're still
around though. These days,
no. Like for example the the story of
the adulterous woman is not found in the
Codex citicus for example and some
people believe that it is fabricated or
the ending of Mark. Some people believe
that
people don't believe that it's a
fabrication. People just believe that
it's not a uh it's not original to like
the the text but it's a true story.
That's the opinion of those people who
don't believe that it it belongs in the
Wait, I'm sorry. How does that work?
It's not supposed to be in the text but
it's a true story. So, why is it not
supposed to be in a text? Or why is
wasn't it there in earlier manuscripts?
What just happened? Am I Can you hear
me?
Yes, I can hear you.
Okay, I I cut out for a second. Did you
hear what I Did you hear what I said?
No.
Okay. Yes.
Wait, what did you say? What did you
say? Just a second. What did you say?
I said that they they still believe that
the adulterous woman
Oh, I heard that. I heard that.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you mean by that? Can you
elaborate?
Mean
it's an oral tradition. It's an oral
tradition that carried on and was and
found its way into the scripture. Um,
but I guess didn't belong originally to
to the gospel accounts, but it's a true
story, you know, that that that carried
on.
So, it's falsely attributed to the
gospel accounts
to to some opinions. Yes.
Like it's okay. What about the ending of
Mark? There are like 12 verses. Then
some people believe that.
What does that have to do with the
question here, brother?
The thing it has to do is the fact that
there are some verses in the Bible that
biblical scholars believe that didn't
exist in the most early manuscripts. Yet
they don't trash the entire Bible going
everything is fabricated since one thing
was fabricated.
So what you have here is let's let's
even go with this most liberal view even
the ending of Mark that the ending of
the longer ending of Mark did not
belong. Um,
yeah. Okay.
They still hold the the New Testament to
be historically reliable on what Jesus
said and did and what happened to him
and what he preached and his message.
Yeah.
So, how does this how does this help the
topic here on you know?
Okay.
So, your point your point was that the
Quran says tells one to look for prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
the gospel and the Torah, right? And
then you also said that the Quran itself
says that it's fabricated or that there
are some parts that are changed.
No, no, no. The Quran doesn't say that.
Muslims were saying he said that the the
guy that was
doesn't say that the scripture has been
changed.
No, it doesn't.
Wait, let me just pull it up. Let me
see.
Okay.
Does it really does it doesn't say that?
Nope.
Let me look for it. Wait, I searched for
it just a second ago. Um, yes. In uh
Quran 3:78 it says there are some who
exist who twist the scriptures with
their tongues to make you people think
that what they say is part of the
scripture when it is not. They say that
is from God when it is not. The
attribute lies to God and they know it.
All right how do they twist the
scripture
with their tongues to make people
believe. So they they uh narrate it. It
is an oral tradition false oral
tradition.
They lie about what the scripture says.
It's a it's a fabricated oral tradition.
They make up stuff and they tell people
about it and later on people can add it
or not add it whether they want or not.
You know the Bible was
soible.
Hold on brother. Hold on. Just slow down
here.
So according to this verse is the
scripture was the scripture textually
corrupted or did people just lie about
what the scripture said?
I'm sorry. Wasn't the scripture itself
an oral tradition which is then later
written later to begin with? Like this
is talking about in Muhammad's time here
is it?
Yeah.
No. What? When where does the verse say
that it is in Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's time?
Read it again.
There are some who twist the scripture
with their tongues to make you people
think that to make you think that what
they Yeah,
there are. So there are presently there
are that's present.
It means they exist
when
it can be any time.
When it says that there are instead of
there was there are is present tense,
right? There are can also refer to the
past. No,
no, that's not past tense. Was is past
tense. There was some among them who
distorted the scripture with their
tongues. That would be past tense. When
it says there are those among them who
distort the scripture with their tongue,
that's present tense. Even though
Well, let me just look at the Arabic.
Let me just look at the Arabic.
Yeah. Yeah.
No, in the Arabic it says, "Surely among
them there is a group." So them is
referring to anyone. No, among so among
them there is right not there was there
is a group among
is in the word is is uh in brackets it's
not in the Arabic
that's that's the that's the uh form of
the word it's in the present tense among
them there is a group yeah but this can
also be referred to the past like there
among the past there is the people who
did this and that did that no how does
it how does it fixate that it has to be
present tense you there
almost. I'm I'm coming back. Just give
me a second.
There's also a hadith where the prophet
peace be upon him says which you know it
uh aligns with this. It says the people
of the book used to read oh the hadith
goes so the messenger of Allah peace
peace and blessings may Allah's peace
and blessings be upon him said neither
believe nor disbelieve the people of the
book but say we believe in Allah and
what has been sent down to us. meaning
like they could say something that's
true. They could say something that's
false which
so he says they can't deny the scripture
but they can they can you know neither
affirm or deny what they say because
what they say might be false of the
scripture right they might be lying
about what the scripture actually says
right
that could be an interpretation yes as
well as
it's not that it could be an
interpretation let's let's just do this
again he says but we believe in what was
sent down to us and to you right
where does it say that
read it again
it says says the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said neither
believe nor disbelieve the people of the
book but say we believe in Allah and
what has been sent down to us
okay it doesn't mention the you part
no
okay so go to suna daw 4449 then
okay 4449
yep
a group of the Jews came and invited
messenger
to kuf so they visited them in their
school they said Abu Kasim is one of our
men has committed fornication with a
woman so pronounced judgment upon them
they placed a cushion for the messenger
of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam who
sat on it and said bring the Torah. It
was brought to them. Then he he then
with withdrew the cushion from beneath
him and placed Torah on it saying I
believe in thee and in him who revealed
thee. He said he then said bring me one
who is learned among you. Then a young
man was brought the transmitter then
mentioned the rest of the tradition of
stoning similar to the one translated by
Malikafri. Yes.
All right. So Muhammad says that he
believes in the in Allah and the one who
revealed that Torah, right?
It was Allah. Yes.
In his time, right?
Does it have to be everything in it?
Because Jesus also affirms of, you know,
the Pharisees.
Can you show me anywhere? Okay, look.
Notice how I was able to give you
something explicit where Muhammad says
that he believes in the Torah that he
has with him. What I need you to do now
is show me where.
Wait, wait, wait. Hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Can I
just finish and I'll let you I'll let
you. I know what you're going to say.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. This is
what happens when you get trapped by
your words.
I'm reading I'm I'm going to read
literally from the scripture that you
gave me.
What I need you to do What I need you to
do is show me where Muhammad says that
he only believes in part of the Torah or
the Gospel or where the Quran says that
it's only confirming part of the Torah
and the Gospel. I need you to show me a
verse or Muhammad saying uh saying that,
please. Uh, okay. I'll bring you that.
But can I just uh this hadith that you
gave me 4449? Can I just uh
uh add something to it? Like
what do you mean add?
Not add but like uh clarify or maybe try
to understand better.
What's what's there to clarify? I I feel
like that
in the clear
the con the the context of this hadith
is that someone uh committed adultery
and now the law of adultery needs to be
uh needs to take place. they need to get
something done. So they take the Torah
as the source of the law for adultery
and he says I believe in this which
would be
that's before the the law of adultery
was shown.
Wait, he believes in the he believes in
the Torah's uh law of adultery. The the
what the Torah says should be done to
adulterous people. He believes in it.
So whatever the Torah said, whatever
that was what was supposed to be done,
right?
Regarding adultery? Yes. Did he say, "I
believe in you and the one who revealed
this part of the law." Or does he is he
does he take the Torah, put it on the
cushion seat, and say, "I believe in
thee, the Torah, and the one who
revealed you." Does he say that or does
he say, "I believe in some of you and
the one who revealed some of you." Is
that what the context of this is that
it's the law of adultery? So I I'm happy
to say that he does believe in the law
of adultery in the Torah being true and
the one who revealed it revealed it.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Show me where Muhammad
says that he believes in only part of
the Torah. Show me that.
No, but he doesn't say I believe in the
whole of the Torah. So it can be it can
go both ways.
Yes, he does. Hey, take take care.
You're too dishonest. Take care. Take
care of yourself, man. Have a good day.